I think we've done a lot of exploring
and this is take your game show I know
where you're going with loss i know are
you go you had been the number one
explorer yes because I get to play final
fantasy explorers what is that since a
three dias game it's not been announced
for the West yet actually like bravely
second has not been announced for lunch
yet but this game is a 3ds game it is a
a light-hearted multiplayer like you
know it's kind of reminiscent final
facing 14 I can that matter yeah well I
don't know that I'd called an mm I don't
know the kevin van order call but it's a
multiplayer online RPG okay and it's a
it's a class-based game it's sort of you
know steeped and all the sort of final
fantasy you know Kootra monster were
used to like the same classes that what
they're always there like I had a
chocobo in my party you know like that
you control one person rather than a
party of people yeah yeah yeah but you
go with a part of your friends out you
tackle missions you tackle quests and
things like that so tell me about the
combat if that's like one of the big
things that yeah it's real-time action
based combat so although the four face
buttons do a you know they command a
certain ability if you hold down the L
button with the R button it brings up
you know a second and third set of
abilities cool so you can have up to 12
at a time but I believe you can actually
have up to 16 if I'm not crazy because I
think there was a time where you could
that's both Ellen are you would bring up
a fourth menu but I think that that's
reserved for attacks that are only
available like once in a while that's
how it was what kind of classes did you
play I only put the knife the demo is
pretty short but there's a night there's
a month as an archer there's a black
mage as a ninja one of the strangest
things about it that definitely gives it
that I'd heard feel apart from
everything else it also does is the fact
that at certain points during a battle I
was fighting II 'fred and like this you
know it was sorta like this fire demon
that's classes in series while showing
off here Aisha every every freakin demo
uh-huh but during that battle there was
icon and the person who was sort of
guiding me through the demos in Japanese
she's like push that button you get to
turn into a classic final fantasy
character what so essentially yeah so
essentially what will happen is it's
almost like a limit break in follow
casey seven right yes i think there's a
meter that builds up and then at one
point you can press this and a character
that I think you've designated
beforehand you turn into him I turn in
the cloud that's also all of a sudden
I'm a little
is crazy and you get to have his moods
like some of the basic commands are the
movies that you chose for my regular
character but on top of that like i did
a river omni / and one of his limit
breaks like i did that on them right and
i know like squall is gonna be there and
I think you know I camera bring you the
Carrick's a look look lak yeah I'm all
bad luck but that's oh that's crazy so
it it's completely separated to all the
other games obviously so this is like
best of really it's like a farm fantasy
just play who just love farm fantasy
yeah it's just like this like a simple
little playground like I kind of liken
it to TI rhythm in my head because it
takes so sure it takes all these things
and just combines them in a game that
isn't trying to be like this serious
like thing that's like innovative and
like you know this groundbreaking RPG
it's just a fun way to kind of enjoy the
series and all the various things that
you may like about so I found fantasy
fans this is a game for them to just
enjoy paul fantasy and different one
yeah but I bet you even if you're not a
fan you might enjoy it anyway because
the controls are responsive its colorful
the art style is really easy to enjoy
and it just seems like a good
multiplayer like dungeon crawling
experience